so I hear you're you're responsible for
his crippling video game addiction oh I
wouldn't talk to the whole video game
addition yep that's me
you all right I introduced them to the
Bethesda like morrowind
and fallout that's the dozer to you when
you went dark deep into it like I was
into I was like I had like a month where
I was like dude Bobby you're gonna get
so immersed yeah and then like I four
months later yeah who cares it's not
it's not a the its they have online
role-playing games now you can no no I
like here's what you introduced me to
the grind right like with Skyrim this
cave has all the blister wart mushrooms
that you can collect and they in it like
what regenerates every week right so
I'll fast forward a week in the game
time just so that I can get more blister
water right so I can make potions to
make smithing better right which which
was kind of what I you know made me drop
off of the game at a certain point it
felt so like you just grind forever yes
I love it
I've been grinding forever it was like
10 years ago a decade ago seriously well
I know it probably was straight-up
2007 I understand that I understand 2007
but well let me say this okay I would
have never [ __ ] known about it if you
didn't go hey you should check out
morrowind i go what the [ __ ] is it so i
went to [ __ ] whatever the place is
you know to get it i bought it and i've
been in it since mm-hmm and you start
over new characters especially with that
with this the bethesda games and also on
skyrim or the elder scrolls there's an 8
races right you can be a Gorian mhm you
can be the Khajiit chat people know i've
you know play
you know I know nor a Nord
yeah Nord [ __ ] yeah see what I'm saying
right now the Dark Elves you can be the
light elves exactly right they're high
elves yeah don't call them yeah I drew
nyan gorya that they got they aren't
that that lizard lizard' yeah do you
ever find yourself like ok 3:30 in the
morning 4:00 in the morning you're just
you're up in some like snowy hill you're
beautiful music playing you look out at
the scenery and you realize it's a dead
world
no it's an empty dead world it comes to
live for me and it doesn't lose you
don't get that I think he's a conqueror
at heart he's look like he's you like to
colonial eyes empty barren areas of the
land
[Music]
[Music]